- Should I try to put these
all in my mouth at once?
- Thanksgiving mega bite.
(crunching)
Is it everything?
- It's going to take a minute.
(upbeat music)
- So today we're trying
Thanksgiving Pringles.
- I personally think Thanksgiving's
one of my least favorite holidays
and that's solely based on
the food that's available.
- In my family, everyone
dresses up like waist up
and wears sweatpants waist
down at Thanksgiving.
- You can just eat all day
long and pass out by like 5.
- Everybody's happy on Thanksgiving
as long as you're not cooking
cause then it's stressful.
- I don't know anything about
these mysterious new Pringles.
- I thought it was just
one Thanksgiving chip.
Just like Thanksgiving flavor.
- Thanksgiving is great and I
think the food is fantastic.
I am interested in ways
to expedite the process
so today's gonna be a cool experiment.
♪ Hallelujah, hallelujah ♪
- So excited.
- Flavoricious.
- Yes.
- It looks like frozen dinners.
- No cooking required.
Come on now, we know.
- It's amazing that we live
in a world where this exists.
All in one little box.
- The only thing I'm not sure of
is the green bean casserole.
- That sounds god awful.
- So we got turkey, mashed potato,
stuffing, mac and cheese, creamed corn.
- Cream. Ew.
- Dubious about that one.
Green bean casserole.
- Ew.
- Cranberry sauce, pumpkin pie.
- That might be better.
- I mean.
- Do you know his name?
- Mr. Pringle.
- No. It's Julius.
Pringle facts.
- It smells like after
you've eaten Thanksgiving
and the turkey's like
already been cut and served.
- Let's do the corn.
(crunching)
It's oddly really sweet.
- I can tell which one the cranberry
one is right now.
- Yeah.
The cranberry is the most conspicuous.
- And another Pringle fact.
Pringle facts.
They only season one side so you're
supposed to eat them seasoning side down.
- You're supposed to
eat Pringles like this?
- Yeah.
- Do you like own equity in Pringles?
- I gotta try creamed
corn with mashed potatoes
cause that's just a classic combination.
- This is sorcery.
How is this working?
I feel like I'm at hometown buffet.
- It tastes just like the
cooked turkey skin on the top.
- I wonder if they just like grind up
dried turkey skin and like sprinkle it on.
- I don't know.
- What will Julius think of next?
- From what I know about
green bean casserole,
it's like barely a vegetable.
- Stuffing.
Whoa, it's very herby.
- Mm. I like this one a lot.
- Easily the best so far.
- Like where's the gravy?
- I'm tasting the gravy.
- Are you?
- I'm tasting the gravy, yeah.
- I wish there was more gravy.
If I had to choose
between seeing my family
or getting pumpkin pie,
I'll catch y'all next year
cause this pie is not going anywhere.
- Alright.
- This smells nice.
- It smells like.
- It smells like home.
- It does smell like
Thanksgiving doesn't it?
- Mhm.
- It's very subtle.
It's like a wave of pumpkin
but like very gentle.
- It's almost, it tasted
a little candle-y.
Like an expensive candle,
not a cheap candle.
Like a fancy candle that
you like, you buy your aunt.
- Eating each of these just made
me want to have the actual food.
- Yeah. I'm so hungry now.
- Maybe if you're that
lazy person that doesn't
want to contribute
anything to Thanksgiving.
- You're not lazy, you're a dick.
- Who wouldn't buy this?
Like, fill the stores with these.
- You have fun with this
with your friends later.
But make a real meal.
- Yeah.
- This isn't a substitute.
(yelling)
Now it's flavored like the floor.